bonsoir aliou barry merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france tout
d'abord une réaction là la forte
participation aujourd'hui à ce scrutin
comment l'expliquez vous 7
d'abord je vous remercie de m'associer à
ce à l'analyse de la situation politique
en guinée mais c'est que cet engouement
s'explique pour une raison très simple
depuis les années 90 dates de départ du
multipartisme a guidé c'est l'un des
rares pays d'afrique de l'ouest qui n'a
pas connu une alternance politique donc
aujourd'hui les guinéens ont soif
d'alternance c'est pourquoi chaque
élection il ya beaucoup d'engouement et
les gens parce que les gens n'ont jamais
connu moi par exemple ma génération on
n'a jamais connu l'alternance politique
en guinée alors que des pays limitrophes
la guinée qui ont ensemble qui ont connu
des crises de graves crises politiques
comme le libéria la sierra leone la
guinée bissao la côte d'ivoire le
sénégal ont tous connu une alternance
politique une alternance démocratique
c'est pourquoi les guinéens à chaque
élection se rendent en masse pour voter
il ya également beaucoup d'électeurs qui
disent avoir voté contre
l'ethnocentrisme c'est le fait de
privilégier évidemment l'ethnie de
laquelle on est issu c'est un peu la
marque de fabrique d'alpha condé est ce
que ça aussi les guinéens veulent
tourner la page mais tout à face avait
un petit il faut savoir aussi que
l'histoire le politique de ce pays est
marqué par l'instrumentalisation du père
noël ethnique s'adapte de béthune et
monsieur sékou touré qui en 1976 avait
déclaré publiquement la guerre open et à
chaque élection depuis 2010 monsieur
alpa condé ressort la même rhétorique
sur l'important le fait de ne pas
permettre à ressortissants de la
communauté peule d'accéder au psn
communauté aujourd'hui devant ce
problème est complètement déterminé et
vote hamas mais il est à mon avis c'est
une erreur de croire que le parti de
l'union des forces démocratiques de
guinée un thème partie technique
j'ai donné en train depuis
l'indépendance de paix de se payer
jusqu'en 2010
à chaque fois le parti au pouvoir et le
parti majoritaire parce que l'animation
et à la disposition de son parti un
conte m
quand même par monsieur diallo
aujourd'hui il s'avère que c'est la
première fois en afrique de l'ouest
qu'un parti d'opposition est majoritaire
et malheureusement l'administration et
le processus électoral un tenus par
l'administration
je ne doute pas de l'uci de cette
collection
en tout cas les deux parties ont appelé
au calme visiblement l'appel a été
entendu ce qui est critique finalement
celle annonce des résultats
on sait que c'est toujours un moment où
ça peut basculer alors tout à fait deux
mois que le solde analyse que j'ai
l'honneur de diriger vient de kerhinet
politique à l'intention de la cedeao
c'est en fait dans des pays comme la
guinée le problème la crise ne naît pas
du processus électoral annonce des
résultats qui a une véritable c'est
pourquoi je crains fort que le lendemain
électoral en guinée soit très sanglant
parce que les deux parties sont dans une
position figée
l'opposition estime monsieur diallo
estiment qu'il est apte en troisième
tentative
fort de l'engouement faire de la
majorité de militants qu'il a il est
persuadé d'être victorieux de l'élection
et michel par condé ne peut pas avoir
fait tous les efforts qu'il a faits de
changer une constitution dans des
conditions vraiment reconnaître et
accepter sa défaite et je pense que la
cédéao devaient aujourd'hui être au
chevet de la guinée parce que le
lendemain électorale 2012
c'est la troisième élection libre
élections pluralistes en tout cas dans
ce pays depuis 1958 deux mandats pour
alpha condé en 2010 et en 2015
il reste néanmoins populaire alpha condé
premier chef d'état en tout cas avoir
été élu démocratiquement
je dis pas ça pour ce qui est un peu
navrant que j'ai oublié tout un pays qui
n'a pas connu une alternance et beaucoup
de guinéens avaient espéré à l'arrivée
de monsieur alpha condé la guinée allait
connaître une alternance pourrait
adresser d'abord c'est du son passé
d'opposant pendant des années au régime
de sékou touré et lansana conté et
surtout l'expérience douloureuse de la
prison qu'il a eu à faire
les guinéens ont estimé qu'ils auraient
fait deux mandats et passer la main
permet enfin à ce pays de connaître une
alternance
malheureusement les guinéens constate
aujourd'hui
que il s'est accroché comme beaucoup de
chefs d'état d'afrique
il a eu sept ce qu'on appelle la maladie
du pouvoir je pense que lille va tout
faire pour être reconduit pour un
troisième mandat qui va entraîner une
véritable l'instabilité politique dans
la guinée quel est le bilan de la
faconde et il ya toujours une grande
misère en guinée alors le paradoxe de ce
pays c'est que mes chers collègues je
sais que je vais appeler le poum la pac
c'est à dire en dix ans il s'est pas
intéressée aux eaux plus occupations
quotidiennes de guinée à dire l'accès à
l'eau l'accès aux soins de santé
primaires
l'accès aux infrastructures il a
construit des hôtels et il a engagé ce
qu'on appelle une exploitation effrénée
de la bauxite
aujourd'hui la guinée en 2019 a été
exportée a produit 70 millions de tonnes
de bauxite a exporté 76 millions tonnes
dans le même temps la guinée si vous
prenez les chiffres de l'office français
de protection des réfugiés
la guinée arrive en deuxième position en
terme de demandeurs d'asile derrière
l'afghanistan et pire le plus que le
pays arrive en tête de mineurs non
accompagnés
parce que tous les guinéens aujourd'hui
la misère qui sévit dans le pays leur
seule solution c'est de quitter le pays
et là c'est le paradoxe à dire que sur
le plan il ya la bauxite qui est
exploité malheureusement les guinéens
vivent aujourd'hui dans une pauvreté
extrême et rssi beaucoup aliou barry
d'avoir répondu ce soir à nos questions
sur arte france